former estate agent graham smith will
tell you the cost of living crisis has
well and truly reached middle england
would you like extra soups
if there's some going yes please which
one do you want i really don't mind he
lost his job at the start of the
pandemic in two years his luxury
lifestyle and his savings have
disappeared without something like the
food bank i just don't know
i mean i've been into eating dry cereal
for the last two days so
yeah it's been very very difficult i
guess you never imagined this would
happen to you absolutely not not not in
a million years i've been on some very
nice holidays i've i've got a car
unfortunately the engine's broken i
can't afford to fix it let alone afford
the insurance mot intact
that really does
hit you
hard it it
affects your self-esteem i'm going to
have to readjust everything that i've
ever known and
lived with and basically just start a
game
so start from the bottom again
single mom amy crome is struggling to
survive even in the short period between
jobs this is her first visit
it's been tough i've wanted to cry but
obviously having my little girl at home
i've had to just
kind of bite my tongue at it
so yeah
it's been tough
at this food bank in slough in berkshire
they say demand for this kind of
voluntary service has never been so high
because they're now seeing people from
all walks of life
this is a crisis affecting middle
england as well isn't it it is for years
people are choosing to eat or heat
that is now becoming a huge reality for
so many more people not just the people
at the bottom of the ladder do you think
that
volunteers
have almost taken over where the state
has fallen away over recent years i
absolutely think that and i think it's
really wrong
slow is predicted to be amongst the
worst hit places in the country but sky
news has been told the cost of living
crisis is triggering unprecedented
requests for help to councils across
england
food banks used to be the cause
sign of demand now we're having families
coming towards and asking council for
support for example for to provide
uniform for their children white goods
fridge freezers cookers and that demand
is
dramatically increasing each and every
week
this is another organisation in slough
supporting the community a
not-for-profit before and after school
club they've been all right today
excellent here even those on a good
salary tell us they're feeling the pinch
single mom nisha kumar works full-time
as a customer service manager taking
home over 40 000 a year i choose to work
really hard and have nice things and
that's a preference of mine i like to
take my children out and enjoy evenings
out you know it's going to be mean that
we've gone out we're going to have to
figure it out and stop let's go winter
2022 and predictions things are going to
get worse lisa holland sky news slow